how's it going bros my name is peter pan
so today it's finally the day where I
can show you bros the Anki tournament or
some highlights of it it was so much fun
to be on stage playing against all these
youtubers with you bros and other fans
in the audience I don't know I just
loved it so I was enjoying my car was
the blue yellow one for Sweden qatal and
yeah we'll see who wins why am i
spinning
they are all off and look how fast
they're going off the beginning there's
no fighting going back and forth corn
eggs Darnay was in the lead now Hoover's
taken well not much don't forget you
need to try and take you to a girl as
you advise taking her again I'm down
into fourth place
Judy pie was in second place
oh it's a three-way tie going through to
the next round
ken of course winning every single race
the most convincing victories we've seen
all day it's only its sign
I do that right this is Brad yard
I got a sense what happened
what is your clapping Duncan is
definitely going through and the next
person going through is PewDiePie what
happened what did I win you win you on
Sunday that's a good [ __ ] Edgar the
first person moving on to the final
round cinnamon toast
hahaha The Tree of Life we please have
Kouta scimitars can purely pie and
Duncan get out here stage guys This Is
It this is what it's all come down to
this is the grand final but UT has taken
its first give anybody till we're off
the bat I was a bracelet but everyone
long time stretches gated by the army
but there's a news photographer go we
throw is disabled
you see there's a
to people disabled oozing beautify with
three disabled ways no no he's down
tried with cervical shut again
no where you guys headed back in a bit
Gibbs every time he's astray get his car
this is going to be bad for Cutie side
nice catch but I feel like this the
battle they've been waiting to happen
for years and versus beauty and the
beauty fine idea get your visa is out
he's gone sweet three boys three months
again till two points to each other
this is a win-win
one more
I don't leer circles my years of
broadcasting can sanitize candies is
gonna be like that I don t wanna know
what to think
Judy pie key Holly
he had it within Ken he can't compose
the whole way through
in second place you go up in except the
second place the man formerly known as
Sonic the Hedgehog
we all know I deserve to win but I'll
guess I'll make an exception for love at
home
this is for my dog Edgar he inspired me
to do this and to all my bros thank you
it really means so much I'll go now all
right well it didn't really show in the
video but the point was to get ten
points in the last match and I had nine
for life forever
I let Ken win don't tell Ken but I
totally let him win so I just wanted him
to have this victory all right that's
something anyway if you bros enjoyed
this video you can do whatever you whine
i just appreciate you watching and as
always stay awesome bro